your rotten tomatoes you can make
anything happen
you gave her wings and blasters so I
take it you didn't have that tech
available for me no I did
so hey I lost this out last night it was
so much fun it was such a cute little
family movie what movies do you like to
watch as a family School of Rock was a
big one okay my house which I also think
that Jack Black's performance in School
of Rock is really one of the greatest
performances of the last 20 years
my daughter is eight and we've been
watching a lot of grease did you get her
to see grease - oh yeah tomorrow we're
seeing Michelle Pfeiffer and my daughter
cannot believe she might actually get to
see Stephanie tsunami I'm not gonna lie
I love her filmography people like
Catwoman I'm like yes I'm like you know
Scarface yes
stephanie's and Oni it was like my thing
I sang those songs still to this day
look at the the pantheon of female
superheroes in fact you're with Michelle
as your mom who played Catwoman like I
was obsessed with her as Catwoman as a
child I fantasized night after night
after night probably for two years of my
life about being her and tried to make
it right I wanted to I did in my
imagination I didn't have the resources
or the skills in real life I think as I
was so obsessed with it I couldn't talk
to her about it I don't want to keep
count on her I don't want to be like an
obnoxious fan I think it was pretty
obvious how stars try Firewise yeah but
working with her on this one talk about
that one because I feel like you guys
have such a great chemistry well it's a
surprise first of all as I didn't know
going in and all of a sudden you get the
script and then Janet you find out we're
gonna be able to find her in the quantum
realm and bring her back and then
Michelle's playing the party I'm just a
tremendous fan of hers you know I'm I
never had the opportunity rumor has it
that you almost worked with her on Basic
Instinct way back when apparently she
auditioned but then they went with no I
I would imagine that God bless appalled
their home in our director but he scared
off most of the women who I mean his
first line when he would Indian High
Hollow they'll be new to Thea lots of
nudity I said Paul easy he's positive
that he's scared to death so I would
imagine and Michelle may have heard the
note that he bit one too many times what
was it like working with Catwoman or did
you guys always
cool I mean I I didn't have a whole lot
of time working with her but I mean
listen just to have the opportunity to
play a scene with Michelle Pfeiffer and
Michael Douglas was was huge you have a
great karaoke moment in this movie
what's your go-to karaoke song from
showing off to Michelle Pfeiffer
yeah oh I'll do anything from The
Fabulous Baker boys soundtrack what is
your go-to karaoke song oh you want to
get with me you got a listen carefully
we got em in the face and like then on
anyway that was key I could do the whole
thing no I have you have to understand I
have a serious I married Katherine who
happens to be a pretty damn good singer
of openers not to mention I opened my
mouth just take a deep breath they say
stop it dead right here stop and right
now please tell me your karaoke okay I'm
not a karaoke er but I have been coerced
into a little couple of drinks yes and
my go-to is proud Mary I of course it is
I get lots of love for doing it people
get know people enjoy it cause it's like
oh good it's great you know it's great
sorry if this is also great from the
film you're on a two-year house arrest
mm-hmm what would you do if you were
stuck inside the house for two years I
would try to learn how to cook because
I'm not going to any restaurants and you
know I would write so many books yeah I
get a major I would read so many books
they'd be a major in quantum mechanics
you might as well learn is exactly the
same things that he does in the movie by
the way this all sounds great
I'm down with are you gonna say the same
thing to me
good job thank you but what's great
about this one we get ant-man and the
wasp and this is the first female Marvel
heroine is it a title role are we fans
of some of the other females like do you
have one that you would make your other
sidekick if you could oh my god they're
all completely badass anyone from Black
Panther yes Scarlet Witch she's maybe
the toughest one of all right and she
can do that then zetz well Scarlett
Johansson is I'm black right I guess oh
yeah we're going character Davis yeah
black color scar Jo you could do it ever
you watch it can I call her blab
talk about the transition from what you
had to do in the first movie to the
second one because it's like night day
you know the first film I actually did
more training like physical training I
had to learn a little bit of kind of
like MMA Muay thai-style boxing
essentially but this film there was so
much thought that went into how she
moved and how she fought because I
suddenly had to take on the mantle of
the wasp which meant I had to
distinguish a new superhero from all the
pantheon of other superheroes that
exists and how do you do that when
there's nothing left like everything's
taken you know every three-point landing
is taken every kind of style is taken
every kick set again how do you make it
fresh and new so there was a lot of time
and effort that like was spent in front
of a mirror with my stunt doubles it's
just trying things and seeing what
worked and also I really wanted her
fight style to be a nod to the original
comic books in the comic books it's a
wildly sexual is like inappropriate yeah
sexual which we wanted to get rid of
that but I still wanted to represent the
grace and elegance and the femininity of
the Oise
[Music]
given how divisive the world is right
now how fragmented how angry how hostile
to have a movie like ant-man on the
wasps worldwide Russians Chinese people
from Africa South America
whenever language they speak they can
come together in the laughs and there's
a common denominator and this to me is
the magic of movies that I love so much
and it just it brings this kind of
brings us all together
[Music]